[Musica]
[Applauso]
la Terra è piatta
credimi la Terra è piatta
sono assolutamente Certo che la terra
sia piatta
qualche anno fa mi è capitato di passare
una bella serata con un gruppo di
persone assolutamente simpaticissime che
hanno tentato di convincermi con
argomentazioni Eh credendoci che la
Terra è piatta Sarà ma io a scuola avevo
imparato che in realtà è una palla un
po' schiacciata in Poi per carità ma non
piatta
questa esperienza mi ha fatto molto
pensare soprattutto mi ha fatto
sviluppare due considerazioni che per me
sono diventate molto importanti Anche
per la mia professione la prima
considerazione è che
abbiamo un problema
attenzione eh ho detto abbiamo non
hanno
un problema perché se ci sono persone
che pensano che la terra sia piatta e ci
credono davvero
Queste persone fanno parte della nostra
società
svilupperanno un pezzo di futuro insieme
a noi
questo è un problema per tutti noi non
per loro
e la seconda considerazione che ho
dovuto Sviluppare e che in realtà
Forse noi abbiamo sbagliato qualcosa
però questa volta noi non significa
tutti noi questa volta noi significa la
mia comunità professionale Gli
scienziati Sì perché anch'io sono uno
scienziato un po' strano perché sono uno
scienziato sociale sapete quelli che
mettono insieme
statistica matematica filosofia e si
sono consegnati il più grande casino di
questa terra da studiare Che cos'è il
comportamento sociale degli individui
che cambiano sapete perché di solito
quando
fai qualche cosa a una molecola non è
che si arrabbia se invece fai qualche
cosa a un essere umano e studi come
reagisce Insomma Questo potrebbe reagire
anche male quindi
la mia il mio mondo scientifico un mondo
scientifico complesso
mi sono chiesto Va bene allora se
abbiamo sbagliato qualcosa se forse c'è
qualche cosa che non abbiamo fatto bene
come possiamo porre rimedio dove sta
l'errore
forse non siamo stati bravi a comunicare
la scienza O meglio non siamo stati
bravi a raccontare davvero bene La
scienza attenzione di nuovo non tanto i
risultati della scienza in quando Siamo
bravissimi
forse non siamo stati bravi a raccontare
quello che sta dietro i risultati a
raccontare noi ricercatori a raccontare
noi scienziati le nostre vite il metodo
che ci sta dietro quello che magari le
persone conoscono un po' meno se non
sono dentro il mondo della Scienza
Eppure è importantissimo perché lì
dentro si può costruire la fiducia nella
scienza si può far capire perché
possiamo fidarci della scienza come un
sapere che forse per alcune domande Anzi
sicuramente per alcune domande è
migliore di altri
e allora
ho provato a sviluppare un modo semplice
per raccontare Che cos'è La scienza e
come funziona
e per farlo Ho provato a immaginarmi un
gioco allora facciamo finta che io abbia
dei poteri magici A noi piacciono i
poteri magici in fondo e che adesso
facendo un bello schiocco di dita
succeda questo
Wow Siamo al buio
ragazzi Il buio
il buio potrebbe essere la nostra realtà
se non ci fosse la scienza vi ricordate
che c'è stato un periodo storico che si
chiamava
oscurantismo c'entra col buio in cui la
scienza non è che era proprio ben vista
ecco allora mi sono detto qual è Intanto
il primo compito della scienza
provare a illuminare questa grandissima
stanza nella quale siamo
accendendo qualche luce
provando a farci scoprire qualche cosa
che sta nel buio e che noi non
conosciamo
per farlo la scienza ovviamente si deve
attrezzare con qualche tecnologia o
meglio con qualche tecnica Ed è
esattamente quello che faremo Allora
prendiamo
uno strumento molto semplice
Guardate una tecnologia meravigliosa
assolutamente innovativa che è stata
sviluppata non so Quanti millenni fa
bene questa tecnologia mi consente di
portare un po' di luce all'interno di
questa stanza ma come tutte le
tecnologie ha dei limiti
come tutte le tecniche di illuminazione
di ricerca ha dei limiti Quali sono i
limiti Beh banalmente
il raggio di luce che Proietta tutto
intorno a me e questo è un pregio
Beh però non è molto profondo riesco a
illuminare dei pezzi della stanza
relativamente piccoli e se voglio
provare a illuminarli bene Devo
spostarmi Inoltre la candela ha un'altra
caratteristica
Proietta una luce che varia un po' i
colori della delle cose che illuminiamo
colori che peraltro ci piacciono molto
spesso perché sono caldi Però c'è un po'
di distorsione
tutte le tecniche di ricerca hanno pregi
e difetti ci aiutano a capire qualche
cosa però ci fanno anche
sperimentare un po' di distorsione
vediamo la stanza in funzione dei limiti
di Queste tecniche di ricerca
Proviamo a cambiare tecnologia
cambiamo tecnologia andiamo di nuovo
nella borsa degli attrezzi del Bravo
ricercatore E che cosa ci troviamo
una torcia elettrica
anche questa Proietta pezzi di luce
nella stanza però ha la caratteristica
di avere un fascio molto molto molto
molto
più ristretto ma mi consente di andare
molto più in profondità Guardate sto
illuminando un sacco di gente in questa
stanza che è molto lontana da me però
sto illuminando un pezzo per volta
mi consente di sperimentare questa
stanza in maniera molto
diversa da quello che facevo con la
candela ma mi fa pagare altri prezzi
peraltro Il grosso problema è che questa
benedetta stanza è veramente grande ci
sarà sempre un pezzo di realtà che non
abbiamo ancora illuminato e come
possiamo fare Allora dobbiamo
attrezzarci
lavorando in squadra abbiamo bisogno di
uno
due tre quattro
mille ricercatori che lavorano insieme
perché la scienza è un lavoro di squadra
però attenti anche questo crea qualche
problemino Perché Perché tutte le
squadre
prima o poi potrebbero anche decidere di
litigare Ma guardate che litigare serve
eh È un modo per comunicare È un modo
per crescere è un modo per fare scienza
perché perché ci consente di
confrontarci ci permette di dialogare ci
permette di scontrarci sulle nostre
convinzioni
La scienza è un lavoro di squadra
che
evolve che stratifica nel tempo la
propria conoscenza e qui avremo bisogno
di un'altra tecnologia essenziale che
ogni ricercatore ha e sapete qual è
questa tecnologia essenziale
intuito creativo sapete perché perché
anche se noi
proietteremo un sacco di fasci di luce
accenderemo un sacco di candele ci
saranno sempre dei pezzi di realtà che
non riusciremo a Illuminare e avremo
bisogno di unire i puntini fra le parti
illuminate unire i puntini significa
poter fare delle ipotesi rispetto a
quello che non vediamo ed è altrettanto
importante che essere bene in grado di
usare le tecniche per illuminare tutte
le parti della realtà che possiamo
illuminare ci fa fare ipotesi ci fa
decidere dove puntare le nostre torce
ma abbiamo ancora un problema
Eh sì perché la scienza è un sapere
cumulativo e non è che possiamo mandare
tutto a memoria E allora arriva un'altra
tecnica fondamentale sapete come si
chiama questa tecnica la prendo sempre
dalla borsa degli attrezzi del
ricercatore è facile facile si chiama
taccuino
sapete che cos'è questo è un hard disk è
un mainframe in cui io scrivo tutto
quello che ho imparato rispetto alla
stanza che ho illuminato qui dentro Io
segno tutti i miei appunti e ho bisogno
di taccuini Fra loro molto diversi
vedete abbiamo tanti taccuini di diverse
dimensioni perché diverse saranno le
mappe che noi tracceremo diversi saranno
i punti di vista diversi saranno i dati
che immagazzineremo
e di nuovo Questo non è uno strumento
che serve solo a me è uno strumento che
io posso dare anche ad altri ricercatori
posso condividere con loro quello che mi
sono segnato sul taccuino e loro possono
controllare come ho fatto a costruire
scienza
e tutte le volte potranno dire sai che
c'è Flavio
hai fatto un errore drammatico non hai
capito assolutamente niente Ricomincia
da capo Anche questo è un pezzo della
scienza
farsi controllare dagli altri e a volte
è pesante Ci vuole un sacco di coraggio
perché
perché la scienza è fatta anche di
grandi cantonate di grandi errori
errori che poi ci permettono di crescere
errori che ci fanno crescere forse
ancora più velocemente di quanto noi
potremmo immaginare
La scienza è tantissime cose e tutte
queste cose sono importanti perché fanno
crescere il nostro futuro la nostra
capacità di sondare quel buio e
aumentare le possibilità di gestire
meglio quel buio
però qui c'è un rischio
se noi non siamo bravi a raccontare
tutte queste cose potrebbe succedere che
ci rifugiamo in un concetto di scienza
che a me non piace
la mia maestra di scienza che è stata
anche maestra di vita
mi ha sempre detto Attento a non fare
della Scienza una religione non è una
religione Tu non sei un sacerdote di una
religione misterica
tu devi raccontarti Devi spiegarti
devi fare tutto quello che puoi per fare
sì che la scienza sia un patrimonio
comune
E allora
a me non suona tanto bene quanto sento
dire la scienza Non è democratica o
meglio Sono perfettamente d'accordo
perché non è che si può votare a
maggioranza se la Terra è piatta o non
lo è
avrei paura a provare a farvi alzare le
mani non lo voglio fare
però la scienza è un pezzo essenziale
della democrazia perché perché se noi
creiamo
persone che sanno e persone che non
sanno
le persone che sanno hanno più potere
E allora noi dobbiamo cercare di fare
evolvere tutta la società
diffondere la conoscenza il più
possibile attenzione questo non
significa
che non possiamo anche ammettere che ci
siano ricerche finanziarie da privati
però se un privato finanzia una ricerca
probabilmente vorrà averne un tornaconto
e questo non ci piace tantissimo se è
l'unico modo di fare scienza
Quindi tutte le volte
che dovrete pensare
quanto è importante che ognuno di voi
finanzi la scienza
la finanzi come un bene pubblico pensate
che in realtà state accendendo come
hanno fatto loro un pezzettino di luce
in quella stanza oscura state aiutando
il mondo a vivere un po' di più nella
luce
e attenzione tutte le volte che voi
vorrete capire come sono state accese
quelle luci avrete il diritto di
chiedere che vi sia spiegato e tutti i
membri della comunità scientifica
dovranno provare a spiegarvelo
Magari possiamo anche immaginare delle
professioni specifiche di persone che
spiegano la scienza
Ma certo la scienza deve raccontare
anche come funziona perché così creiamo
fiducia
La scienza è una bellissima storia ed è
una storia che dobbiamo raccontare tutti
non c'è il copyright su questa cosa Se
lo fate anche voi mi fate felice Grazie
[Applauso]